- [Voiceover] Four unit
squares each have 4/5
of their area shaded,
and we see that here.
If we had this whole thing
shaded in, that would be
a whole, but we only
have 4/5 of it shaded in.
It's split up into five equal sections,
and 4/5 are shaded in.
So this is a fifth, that's another fifth,
that's another fifth,
and that's another fifth,
so we have 4/5 shaded in.
And we have these 4/5 four times,
so you could view this entire shaded area
as four times 4/5.
So all of this we could view
Well, what is this going to be?
What is the total area that is shaded?
And I encourage you to
pause the video and try to
think about it.
Well, each of these bars,
this right over there,
that is a fifth.
We've already seen that.
If you took a whole and you split it into
five equal sections,
one of those sections
is going to be a fifth.
That's a fifth right over there.
So how many fifths are shaded in?
Well, that's, let me do
this in a color you can see.
This is one.
I didn't switch the colors.
This is one, 2/5, 3/5, 4/5,
5/5, 6/5, 7/5, 8/5,
9/5, 10/5, 11/5, 12/5,
13/5, 14/5,
15/5,16/5.
We have 16/5 shaded in.
So what is the total area that is shaded?
We can say 16/5
are shaded in or 16/5 square units,
where whole would be one square unit,
but we have 16/5 of the square units
actually shaded in.
Let's do another example.
What is 2/3 of six?
Well, we have six triangles here,
and you can see that they're
giving us a little hint,
and they've divided it into thirds.
They've divided it into
three equal groups.
Notice that's one equal group,
that is two equal groups,
and that is three equal groups.
So each third, so each of these thirds,
this is 1/3 of six.
We see that 1/3 of six is two,
but we want 2/3 of six,
so that's going to be
two of these groups of 1/3.
So that's one group of 1/3 of six,
and that's another 1/3 of six.
1/3 of six.
So if you took both of these together,
you're going to have 2/3 of six,
and we see that that is one,
two, three, four triangles.
So that is four triangles.
Let's do another one,
and this one's a little
bit more interesting.
What is 5/8 of four?
And we have drawn here four holes.
This is a hole, this is
a hole, this is a hole,
and that's a hole, and we
see that they're split.
Each of the holes is split
in two, so this is 1/2.
This is another 1/2.
This is 1/2.
That's another 1/2.
That's 1/2.
Now, why do they do this?
Why did they give us a hint?
Well, we see that each half is actually
1/8 of the entire four holes.
What am I talking about?
Well, if I were to take
all of these four holes,
and if I were to divide them
into eight equal sections,
this is one of the eight equal
sections right over here.
It just happens to be half of a whole.
So if I'm talking about, so
one way to think about it is
if I say 1/8 of four,
that's going to be equal to 1/2.
You see it here.
We have four holes, and if
I were to divide that into
eight equal sections, that
would mean taking each hole
and dividing it into two,
so half is 1/8 of four,
but that's not what they're asking us.
They're asking, "What's 5/8 of four?"
So this is 1/8.
This is 2/8.
This is 3/8.
This is 4/8.
This is 5/8.
So what is that going to be all together?
So I just wanna remind you 'cause
it could be a little confusing.
I'm saying eighths and
halfs and all of that.
Remember, 1/8 of four is 1/2, so two.
Let me shade this in, and we'll do this
with a different color.
So 1/8 of four,
I wanna do a lighter color.
So 1/8 of four is 1/2,
2/8 is two halfs,
3/8 is three halfs.
4/8 is four halfs,
and 5/8 is five halfs.
So I've just shaded. Notice
I took the whole four.
I divided it into eight equal sections,
and I've shaded in five of them.
One, two, three, four, five.
Now, how many is that total?
Well, each of those are a half.
This is (mumbles).
This is 1/2,
this is another half, that's another half,
that's another half,
and that's another half,
so altogether I have five
halfs that I have shaded in.
So that is five halfs.
Let's do one more.
What is 4/5 of ten?
And, once again, I encourage
you to pause the video
and try to think about it.
Well, we see here on the number line,
they've taken from zero to ten,
and they have split it into
five equal sections, so each of this,
so this right over here,
this is 1/5 of 10.
If you go from zero to 10,
you'd write into five equal sections.
This is one 1/5 of ten.
Let me write that down.
This is 1/5
of 10 right over here.
Now, what number is that?
Well, we see that that number is two.
Two is 1/5 of 10.
1/5 of 10 is equal to two.
Well, they're not just
asking us 1/5 of 10.
They're asking us 4/5 of 10.
So this is 1/5 of 10,
2/5 if we go,
actually, let me go this way.
So let me do it with another color.
So this is 1/5 of 10.
Now we're gonna go 2/5 of 10,
3/5 of 10, and we go all
the way to 4/5 of 10,
which get us to this
number right over there.
Now, what number is that?
Well, we see this is zero,
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
so it's the number eight.
So what is 4/5 of 10?
It is the number eight.